[Music]
in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show you what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us in the age of video games
smartphones and the internet public
libraries across the country are getting
creative to draw people in many are
lowering late fees or forgiving
forgiving them altogether
Jamie yuccas shows us how one Southern
California County is letting young
readers work off their fines by opening
up a book Mildred and Sam lived in a
tiny house underneath the daffodil roots
they see little teeth what the hens with
teeth EPIK East LA library the other
dogs often match even the youngest
patrons have to pay their dues but not
the way you think how high have your
fines been before $45 yeah card holders
21 and under can literally read away
with the oh in late fees at a rate of $5
per hour it's a new chapter for Los
Angeles County a program called the
great read away we're not really
concentrated on what they're reading so
long as they're reading LA County
Library director Skye Patrick says the
idea came about after the library
noticed an unsettling trend that fines
are not fine many kids who racked up
debt on overdue books or movies would
stop coming to the library altogether
$10 absolutely yeah for some people
that's a huge barrier and those are the
kids that you want in the library
reading that's exactly it
so this program is really to invite them
back into the library to make libraries
accessible to them and their families
we found 8 year old jaelyn Robles
working off her late fee while also
catching up on the popular Judy Moody
series when you didn't have to pay money
for your fines and you could read away
your fine what did you think and it's
just right
why were you surprised I thought that
everybody in the library or someone that
has a fine they have to pay about five
to six hundred kids come through our
doors on a daily basis children's
librarian Schumann's on says she sees
kids reading away fees daily did you
ever see an astronomical fine that you
thought oh my gosh the kids aren't gonna
be able to read this away I've seen as
low as a couple of cents to as high as a
couple of hundred dollars and I've seen
kids read that away because they have
the commitment to do so since the
program launched last year LA County
says it's more than 80 libraries have
logged more than fifty thousand reading
sessions and reinstated more than 13
thousand previously blocked accounts do
you think the library has given you guys
a love of books and so and that's gonna
be with you forever yeah a price well
paid for these page turners for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles libraries
really are magical we all have great
memories as kids great story and if you
have a story you would like to see
highlighted in our more perfect union
series we want to hear from you you can
submit your story idea on our website
CBS this morning calm